i really think i'm in a good place
khloe kardashian shot to stardom in 2007
with the launch of keeping up with the
kardashians
and has been dubbed fan favorite ever
since
what is wrong with people they love her
what is wrong with you
from chloe's hilarious sense of humor to
her brutal honesty and
boss lady mentality chloe's proved she
deserves the title
amen sister
clone money is an inspiration to many
with several business ventures under her
belt
before becoming a reality star chloe
co-owned the clothing store dash
and later expanded her empire with the
2016 launch of good american jeans
and has since grown into swimwear and
athleisure
chloe also went on to write a book
strong looks better naked
which is a blessing posted a few
television shows
including x factor cocktails with chloe
and revenge body and wow you've had the
most amazing year
i have everything that you would ever
dream of is coming true
get it true i get it i get it
speaking of revenge bod
you spent so many years
getting in the best shape of your life
and then you got pregnant
chloe's a beast in the gym and never
seems to miss a day
often sharing her intense workouts on
instagram
chloe's dedication to her fitness
continued during pregnancy
this is a lot you should not be doing
this pregnant
you might hurt yourself and she opened
up to e.t about what it was like
bouncing back post birth i was really
proud of myself how
i thought i would be a little more
insecure because i worked so hard to get
my body before i got pregnant
um and i well i felt really good i think
after you have a baby you just feel
empowered and
just the fact that you're now able to
juggle a child working out and work
i think that's an accomplishment so i
felt really good that i found
my groove and that i was trying chloe
definitely found her groove and
continues to show off her results
on the gram of course
[Music]
chloe's worked on herself so much over
the years not only physically
but mentally as well taking an anger
management class back in 2009
after slapping her now bestie scott
disick
during this class i'm realizing that you
know my anger that i have for scott is
not really about him it's about the fact
that
i feel like i'm losing courtney and that
i feel like she's being taken away from
me
we've seen her growth continue to play
out on keeping up i'm just really sorry
for
my short temper with you and i'm working
on it i'm trying to better myself
but we sure do love her sometimes savage
honesty
i don't like watch tv like no one cares
you don't get an award because you watch
less tv although chloe and scott have
had their flare-ups since the slap
if like you need to get your wet that
badly then get your
what i had a baby blue shirt on
they always bounce back because hey
they're family
that's my girl and chloe is loyal af
[Music]
because no one understands how it's i'm
not just a tv show
like this is my life and it like breaks
my soul and it's happened so many times
chloe has had a few hiccups with
love over the years remember her public
split with lamar odom
and her brief yet dramatic fallout with
boyfriend tristan thompson
with whom she shares daughter true
[Applause]
coco seems to come out the other side
stronger and wiser
and that's a beauty and it's hard work
for all parties and i think everyone has
to handle their co-parenting situation
in their own style but my mom and my dad
were like that it took them years but my
dad would come over
once a week for family dinners and would
play golf with my stepdad and
so we come from a family where we
believe in that and you share
children with people and that's how it
should be
chloe will ride with you when times get
tough
don't worry about mom focus on your
photo shoot who the hairs i'm going to
be so much more like inspirational than
mom could ever be mom would try to jump
in your photos
some of her best friends have been with
her since day one including
malika hack who coco's often
collaborated with on business ventures
from
dash dolls to their becca cosmetics
beauty collab
what is it like working with your best
friend the best thing ever
that's what we know
you can always count on chloe to be down
for a good prank
oh hey chris fire the saga continues
park right out front break a leg
yeah yes you forgot something you threw
something out now you lost it
we're going to get christy our pr
representative to leak the photos
we cannot wait we think it's more
authentic and genuine
when we do these pranks we go we go all
in
coco's dressed up like her mom on a few
occasions oh my god
matt vodka
oh thank you you have my birkin right
yes okay thank god
[Music]
and got her good when she was quote
scamming her daughters into buying her
gifts
chloe and kim plotted their revenge with
two cakes to the face
huh what
[Music]
glowing what is wrong with you
but kim's not always on the giving side
in fact she's been on the receiving end
of chloe's behavior as well
but fans don't just root for chloe
because of her jokester personality and
savage attitude she's well-rounded with
a gentle spirit
um who spoils their kids the most
i actually probably chloe i don't spoil
my kids i try to not
give them lots of gifts for their
birthday i'm like the anti
i mean she's 18 months old and it's my
first
baby so i think you do more with the
first
two and then you kind of because you're
like waiting for
any opportunity to get them something
like the things you've dreamt your whole
life to get
yeah we're just on elmo right now it's
like i'm buying our car
elmo yeah not yet chloe's soft spot
definitely her daughter true my favorite
part about being a mom i mean it's so
corny but it's just like no matter how
tired you are
whatever you just it's complete bliss
and like i think also motherhood just
puts
life into perspective and what's
important to you and and i still think
people who don't have kids there's
definitely there's things that are
important to them too because i felt
that way
but i think you just re-evaluate things
like i don't want to do that tonight and
it's okay to say no so i can spend time
with my family
chloe's alluded to giving true a sibling
i just feel like it's now time
to have another kid and opened up to e.t
about the possibility in 2019.
like right now i'm super content with
just true yeah
and again i guess just i have to see on
the situation i don't feel like it's
kind of one and done too yeah and i
never thought i would have only
one child but i am so obsessed with her
and i love it so much i definitely
don't think i would feel incomplete if i
didn't have more
but another one would just add more love
to the house so i don't know yet
it's gonna be it's hard this is like a
family-making kind of family
yeah like to just have one that goes
against everything that
is it it really is and that's the only
thing was i just
like born to believe i need to have so
many kids i don't know but i'm so happy
with just her so only time will tell
we hope so the world needs more people
like clow money
you